Welcome back! Now,
after the tragic events
in Orlando,
many politicians are rallying
around the LGBT community,
including Florida
attorney general, Pam Bondi.
And we are making it clear
anyone who attacks
our LGBT community, anyone
who attacks anyone in our state,
will be gone after with...
to the fullest extent
of the law.
Yep, nice words.
But unfortunately
for Attorney General Bondi,
Anderson Cooper was there
to go all 360 on her ass.
You basically had gone
after gay people,
said that...
in court, that gay people,
simply by fighting
for marriage equality,
were trying to do harm
to the people of Florida.
Do you really think you're
a champion of the gay community?
Oh...
snap!
Anderson's goin' off!
Damn, you do not want
to make Anderson Cooper mad.
He will... respectfully ask you
some questions
about the cases you oversaw
against gay marriage.
Are you saying you did not
believe it would do harm
-to Florida?
-Of course not.
Of course not. G-Gay peo...
No, I've never said that.
The only time that
much stuttering doesn't mean
you're lying is when
it's in a dance remix, right?
♪ G-Gay people ♪
I have never really seen you
talk about gays and lesbians
and transgender people
in a positive way until now.
Um, I read your Twitter history
for the last year,
and I saw you tweeting about,
you know, National Dog Month.
You never even tweeted
about Gay Pride Month.
Wait, hold on. He read
her Twitter history for a year?
I don't know
whether he's a good journalist
or just a stalker at this point.
Maybe both.
And, yes, she tweeted
about National Dog Month,
but we checked
and she never sent one tweet
about National Gay Dog Month.
That's just wrong.
But, but Pam had a solid defense
for that, too.
Well, actually, if you look
at my, um, Web site now
-we have hands clasped together,
-Mm-hmm.
um, all different color,
rainbow hands and people.
-So you just put that up now?
-So... Yeah, I did,
-after this horrible tragedy,
absolutely. -Right. Right.
(laughs)
"So you just put that up now?
Oh, you just put that up now?"
Absolutely. She will show
respect for minority groups
when there's
a stock image available.
Except-- spoiler alert--
there are no rainbow hands
on Pam Bondi's site.
-(groaning)
-She didn't even do
the one bull(bleep)
political move she said she did!
(groans)
Here, Pam, let me help you out.
(cheering and applause)
There you go.
Okay. Now, it's been 24 hours
since the interview,
which apparently isn't enough
time to find some rainbow hands,
but it should be enough time
to set the record straight.
Or, well, you know.
BONDI (speaking):
Yeah, you-you could have been
helping,
by clearing up your bull(bleep).
And, for good measure, she
doubled down on her non-apology.
BONDI (speaking):
No, no.
The Florida gay community
already hated you.
They already did.
You d...
It didn't encourage it, no.
For... You know,
for the whole saying
gay marriage
would cause public harm thing,
insinuating that gay parents
don't create stable homes thing,
and, of course,
the gay friends excuse thing,
when asked about gay marriage.
Are you personally against it?
You know,
I-I have so many gay friends.
Jason at Starbucks
is not your friend, okay?
And, and he's straight!
Stop judging guys with man buns,
all right?
Okay?
Not right.
Now, I have to say this though,
guys, I have had my issues
with CNN in the past.
I'm technically not allowed
to appear on their network.
But, but I have to give credit
where credit is due.
Anderson Cooper, for doing
what we should be seeing
on cable news all the time,
I am giving you
a half-stand full clap.
(cheering and applause)
Way to do your job, man!
Way to do your job!
And I still got my eye on you,
Wolf.
And Becky with the good hair.
We'll be right back.
(cheering and applause)